this is funny
john stamos jokingly blames his late
friend bob saget for his son billy's
latest obsession it's really funny the
actor shared this cute video of the
three-year-old watching an early episode
of full house
this is funny
john explains in the caption billy was
never interested in full house and i was
perfectly fine with that bob died now
he's obsessed i blame bob stay cool take
us home boys
take your cell phone
this is funny
the sweet moment got over a million
views in less than a day and the comment
section is full of joy bob's wife kelly
rizzo gushed i love this john the last
four years we started to become
close the last four years of the eight
year run of the first one and then since
then
we literally
are brothers and that brotherhood lives
on as john continues to pay tribute to
bob by sharing fond memories
the grandfathered star shared that
musical moment on monday john on piano
and bob on guitar performing a duet
[Music]
[Applause]
john writes quote me and bob hacking
through unchained melody miss him so
much tonight when you care about
somebody
especially now i'm finding
you you got to let them know but stamos
is far from the only one celebrating
bob's life and legacy earlier this week
john mayer dave chappelle jeff ross seth
green and more comedians performed a
punk rock shiva at the comedy store in
west hollywood in honor of their late
pal also up on stage at the punk rock
shiva bob's wife kelly the blogger
shared these pics channeling her late
husband by doing a stand-up routine
kelly notes in her caption that bob
would have gotten a huge kick out of me
being up on stage she says i know it
made him smile big it's a gift to be
able to be with people and make him
laugh the punk rock shiva was
intentionally held at the comedy store
it's where the late comic got his foot
in the door over 40 years ago in 1992 et
spoke with bob at the special venue i
have a lot of loyalty to it this was my
grad school i quit grad school at usc at
film school to come here because like
the doors opened up so i said how many
people get to be a regular non-paid
regular at first but uh and i was
putting like i mean a college tour and
all the stuff that i got out of the
comedy store and the experience of it
and knowing what it's like to deal with
other comics i mean these are my friends
and it is like there's a bond that we
all knew each other for so long that you
can't
you don't forget